la nación del vudú la cuna de los zombis
la tierra [__] vigilada por el barón
Sandy laloa de la muerte según la
tradición todo esto y más es Haití una
tierra caribeña poblada por demonios
capaces de arrebatarle su voluntad a
muchos haitianos queridos amigos amigas
de visualpolitik esto al menos es lo que
pensaban muchos franceses cuando está
todavía era su Colonia de Santo Domingo
o también los propios estadounidenses
cuando invadieron el país en el año
1916 de hecho sabíais que los zombies se
popularizaron en Estados Unidos justo
durante la invasión estadounidense de
principios del siglo XX Pues sí esa ha
sido la influencia de este país Claro
que seamos honestos esta percepción tan
macabra de Haití y de su población
servía a un propósito muy concreto poder
dominar un territorio que había ser la
colonia más rica del mundo y que ocupaba
una posición absolutamente estratégica
en el Caribe Y es que Haití podría
haberse llegado a convertir en uno de
los países más ricos de América Latina
sin embargo el destino le tenía
preparado otro camino muy diferente uno
que le llevaría a convertirse Ni más ni
menos que en el país más pobre de
América Latina del hemisferio norte y
uno de los más pobres de todo el planeta
más allá del vudú los zombies y los
espíritus hoy por hoy Haití es
prácticamente lo que podríamos denominar
como un estado fallido
[Música]
Haití lleva en una espiral de
inestabilidad política desde su
independencia en 1804 en estos dos
siglos han sido muy pocos los gobiernos
que se han mantenido estables de hecho
seguramente la época más estable del
país fue también la época más cruel
hablamos de la dictadura familiar de
françois duvalier alias papadoc y tras
su muerte la de su hijo Jean Claude
entre ambos estuvieron casi 30 años en
el poder y establecieron uno de los
regímenes de terror más extremos de toda
la historia pero eso será tema para otro
vídeo Así que no olvides suscribirte si
es que aún no lo has hecho El caso es
que por supuesto toda esta inestabilidad
no fue algo fortuito tras su
independencia ahí tienedo una enorme
tensión social basada en la raza que
hizo que la violencia se convirtiera en
toda una seña de identidad nacional sin
embargo ahora las cosas son incluso peor
la violencia ha estallado descontrolada
y Campa a sus anchas grandes partes del
país están en manos de bandas y la
hambruna acecha por eso el presidente
interino Ariel Henry está buscando una
manera de frenar la violencia de las
bandas para lograrlo está mirando a dos
de sus vecinos Estados Unidos y El
Salvador La pregunta es qué ha causado
exactamente la desolación de Haití Qué
ha hecho que el país esté en manos de
bandas y grupos criminales Cómo espera
el gobierno haitiano mitigar la
violencia Qué capacidad tiene para
lograrlo hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
la eterna castigada de la historia
[Música]
no creo que sea una sorpresa para nadie
Si digo que entre los países más pobres
del mundo encontramos lugares como
burundi somalia o Sierra Leona Pero qué
ocurre si nos centramos exclusivamente
en América pues ocurre exactamente Esto
sí Muchos podríais pensar que Venezuela
y su Revolución bolivariana forman el
país más pobre de América sin embargo ya
lo veis Haití sigue sacando ventaja Y es
que veréis las cosas empezaron muy mal
desde muy pronto tras su independencia
de Francia la potencia europea inició un
duro bloqueo contra su ex Colonia y la
exigió el pago de 150 millones de
francos lo que convertido en dólares y
ajustado a la inflación vendrán a
suponer más de 700 millones de dólares
Claro que eso no fue lo peor ni tampoco
la ocupación meramente extractiva de
recursos que Estados Unidos protagonizó
entre 1916 y 1934
[Música]
lo peor fue la propia dinámica de este
país las tensiones entre la población
negra y la mulata se intensificaron cada
vez más y más las luchas por el poder
fueron constantes los golpes de estado
se sucedieron uno tras otro y los
asesinatos presidenciales no fueron algo
extraño todo por supuesto bañado con un
montón de corrupción un concepto de
corrupción vamos que lo que se dice
estabilidad Pues precisamente ha
brillado por su ausencia sin ir más
lejos yo ven el mois el presidente que
fue asesinado en 2021 también estaba
implicado en Casos de corrupción es algo
así como la norma predominante miles de
personas protestan contra la corrupción
en Haití los manifestantes exigen la
dimisión del presidente yo ven el mois
por no atajar la corrupción meses de
protestas han envuelto al país más pobre
del hemisferio occidental con todo la
característica más llamativa de Haití a
lo largo de sus 200 años de
Independencia y sobre todo en las
últimas seis décadas ha sido la
violencia
[Música]
en 1951 el dictador haitiano françois
duvalier creó los tontos macut una
milicia cuyo objetivo era aumentar el
control del tirano sobre el país y
reducir el peso y la influencia del
ejército un ejército que había sido
entrenado por Estados Unidos durante su
ocupación y que no le era
particularmente Leal es decir el
dictador diseñó una especie de guardia
pretoriana a su servicio personal para
controlar las calles y cuando su hijo
Jean Claude duvalier fue Finalmente
derrocado y se disolvió esta milicia de
repente empezaron a proliferar todo tipo
de bandas milicias y grupos
paramilitares digamos que los miembros
de los Tom Tom macut se buscaron nuevos
empleos amigos amigas la cosa aún fue a
peor cuando en 1995 el presidente John
bertrand aristit que en 1991 había sido
derrocado por el ejército y que volvió
al poder en 1994 gracias a la ayuda de
Los Yankees decidió disolver las fuerzas
armadas Y qué fue lo que pasó a
continuación
Pues como ya hicieron los antiguos
miembros de los tontos macut muchos
soldados también se buscaron un nuevo
empleo en el sector que mejor conocían
es decir se enrolaron en bandas y grupos
guerrilleros o directamente las crearon
como buenos emprendedores bandas que
empezaron a colaborar con las diferentes
facciones políticas de hecho el propio
presidente aristic el que disolvió el
ejército tenía sus propias guerrillas
las quimeras que se encargaban de atacar
a la oposición y a callar a la
disidencia Y así fue hasta 2004 cuando
volvió a ser derrocado esta vez por una
banda conocida como ejército caníbal
junto al grupo paramilitar frente
revolucionario para el avance y el
progreso de Haití y así queridos amigos
es como Haití se convirtió en una
especie de partida eterna de risk para
las bandas los paramilitares y los
grupos criminales ellos imponen su ley y
claro entre las luchas de poder los enfr
movimientos sociales la corrupción y la
violencia generalizada no nos puede
extrañar encontrarnos con noticias como
estas la ONU alerta de niveles
catastróficos de hambre en zonas de
Haití en un país de apenas 12 millones
de personas casi cinco están al borde de
la hambruna y de todas ellas más de la
mitad son niños a esto además hay que
sumarle la epidemia de cólera que está
atravesando el país y que ha dejado Ya
al menos 15.000 casos y 450 muertos que
se sepa la situación es crítica Y ante
situaciones críticas llegan medidas
desesperadas atentos
[Música]
un presidente
desesperado
ya os lo hemos dicho la extrema
violencia de Haití No es algo
precisamente nuevo sin embargo lo que
todavía no hemos dicho Es que desde el
año 2021 los niveles de violencia y
criminalidad han alcanzado niveles no
vistos desde la dictadura de duvalía y
la pregunta es por qué Pues básicamente
por el asesinato de yo benelle Moisés
el presidente mois se vio implicado en
un escándalo de corrupción relacionado
con la malversación de fondos de
petrocaribe el proyecto auspiciado por
Venezuela para vender su petróleo en la
región ahora bien su presidencial no
solo estuvo marcada por la corrupción
también por perpetuarse en el poder sin
convocar elecciones cuando correspondían
y seguiré la presidencia una vez que su
mandato terminó el 7 de febrero de 2021
al final en julio de ese mismo año fue
asesinado por una milicia compuesta
principalmente por colombianos claro que
el asesinato a día de hoy sigue siendo
un misterio dos de los sicarios eran
informantes de la DEA y varios habían
sido entrenados por el ejército
estadounidense se barajan varias
hipótesis Pero la más sonada apunta que
mois fue asesinado justo antes de
publicar una lista de narcotraficantes a
perseguir
sea como sea el hecho es que mois fue
derribado y como siempre ocurre el vacío
de poder es rápidamente cubierto por
otros actores y aquí es donde aparece
uno de los grandes protagonistas de este
vídeo Ariel Enric presidente interino
Primer Ministro y ministro del interior
de Haití
[Música]
Y si algo es incuestionable Es que desde
su toma de Posesión Henry ha tenido una
enorme oposición neurocirujano y ahora
presidente interino el hecho es que es
tremendamente impopular gran parte de
los haitianos le ven como un presidente
ilegítimo y no solo porque haya sucedido
una presidencia cuyo mandato ya había
vencido sino también porque se ha negado
a celebrar elecciones Pese a que
prometió que para finales del 22 ya
habría una fecha para los comicios sin
embargo luego argumento que no se daban
las condiciones necesarias Así que lejos
de producirse la convocatoria electoral
vencidos todos los plazos nos
encontramos con noticias como esta Haití
se queda sin cargos electos en una
espiral hacia la anarquía los 10 últimos
senadores dejan sus cargos con las
bandas controlando gran parte de la
capital una crisis de malnutrición y un
brote de cólera es decir que además de
que Henry se ha negado a abandonar la
presidencia ahora se suma el hecho de
que ya no diputados ni senadores porque
sus mandatos han terminado para que os
hagáis una idea hasta las bandas están
reclamando elecciones pero como Enric ha
decidido sordos la violencia se ha
disparado aún más por ejemplo en apenas
los cuatro años que transcurrieron entre
2018 y 2022 el número de homicidios
prácticamente se triplicó hasta tocar la
Barrera de los 20 homicidios por cada
100.000 habitantes lo que lo convierte
en uno de los países más peligrosos del
mundo las bandas han salido la calle
para lograr lo que sus socios no pueden
conseguir en las urnas el poder sobre
gran parte del país y especialmente
sobre buena parte de la capital Puerto
Príncipe
nutriéndose del tráfico de narcóticos y
de armas las bandas sobre todo las
afines a la coalición de bandas
denominada g9 han conseguido tal y como
podéis ver en el mapa hacerse con el
control de buena parte de la costa de la
Bahía de Puerto Príncipe el neurálgico
de la economía haitiana de hecho para
que os hagáis una idea el llamado g9 ha
llegado incluso a tomar la principal
terminal petrolífera del país la
terminal barró lo que hizo que Haití se
sumiera en un caos Total ya que el
petróleo es la principal fuente de
energía es decir recapitulemos tenemos
un país tomado por las bandas con tasas
de violencia altísimas mucha corrupción
un brote de cólera el menor ingreso per
cápita de toda América ausencia de
instituciones y un presidente que no
quiere dejar el poder En otras palabras
tenemos todos los ingredientes posibles
para situar al país al borde del colapso
Y esa es precisamente en la situación en
la que se encuentra Haití Y eso ha hecho
que el propio presidente Ariel Enric
tomara esta decisión el gobierno
haitiano solicita ayuda militar
internacional Exacto queridos amigos de
visualpolitik el propio presidente
haitiano ha pedido que otros países
intervengan en el país especialmente
Estados Unidos pero la pregunta es quién
demonios estaría dispuesto a llevar a
cabo semejante operación es decir a
desplegar tropas para luchar contra las
bandas y el narcotráfico en un país
completamente roto de verdad creéis que
esto es siquiera posible pues la verdad
no lo parezco
[Música]
de hecho Estados Unidos no quiere bajo
ningún concepto tener que volver a
enviar tropas como ya hizo En 1916 y
1994 sin conseguir prácticamente nada
excepto situada en el poder a gobiernos
autoritarios que empeoraron aún más las
cosas por eso Washington escurrió el
bulto y le pasó la pelota a Canadá a lo
que rápidamente troudó se negó dijo que
Canadá no organizaría esa intervención
salvo que existiera unanimidad entre
todos los actores políticos del país
algo que como os podéis imaginar es
prácticamente imposible y la pregunta es
Entonces qué quizás la ONU pues no
tampoco tiene pinta De hecho hace
relativamente poco que la ONU acabó su
misión de estabilización en Haití y
aparte de cosechar un fracaso más que
obvio para colmo la intervención de Los
cascos azules estuvo repleta de polémica
por haber Aparentemente provocado varias
violaciones de mujeres haitianas
asesinatos encubiertos la introducción
del cólera en el país etcétera etcétera
vamos que es casi seguro que esta vez la
ONU prefiera mantenerse al margen por
eso lo que ha propuesto Naciones Unidas
es que esta intervención la lleve a cabo
un país que creo muchos no esperabais
ver en toda esta historia sí estamos
hablando de los Estados Unidos Mexicanos
Sí sí de México y Por qué México
Pues básicamente por la experiencia que
este país tiene en la lucha contra el
crimen organizado Y no sólo eso también
conseguiría aliviar la llegada de
refugiados haitianos a sus costas sea
como sea esta opción por el momento está
paralizada algo así como a ver a ver un
momento que bastantes problemas tenemos
ya nosotros pero entonces está Haití
avocado a que las bandas se hagan con
todo el control terminará estallando el
país pues de momento lo que sabemos es
que al presidente le ha llamado la
atención otra estrategia de seguridad
una estrategia que ha copado de noticias
la prensa internacional Seguro seguro
que muchos ya os hacéis una idea atentos
el plan bukele para Haití
[Música]
efectivamente queridos amigos hoy
tenemos que volver a hablar del polémico
bukele para muchos el artífice de romper
cualquier equilibrio Sensato entre
seguridad y Libertad en El Salvador y
para otros El Mesías de la paz en
Latinoamérica ya os hemos hablado tanto
en visualpolitik como en not news
nuestra gratuita a la que os podéis
suscribir en not news.com sobre lo que
busque él está haciendo en El Salvador
pero por si alguien está perdido os lo
vamos a resumir
en líneas generales el presidente
salvadoreño ha implantado una estrategia
de extrema mano dura contra las
pandillas y el crimen que asolaba en el
país amilitarizado la seguridad pública
y proporcionado mejor equipamiento tanto
a militares como a policías además para
poder llevar a cabo su drástica
estrategia decretó un estado de
excepción que le ha permitido suspender
varios derechos fundamentales como la
inviolabilidad de la correspondencia la
privacidad de las comunicaciones el
derecho a la defensa o la libertad de
asociación una medida que también le ha
permitido no de tener a pandilleros y a
presuntos pandilleros sin necesidad de
tener una orden judicial junto a todo
ello ha adoptado también medidas
controvertidas como las penas de cárcel
de hasta 15 años por hacer grafitis
alusivos a las maras la reducción de
alimentos y confiscación de colchones en
las cárceles y la imposición de
sanciones a medios de comunicación que
publiquen mensajes de las pandillas
en otras palabras que ha obviado de
manera descarada la protección de los
derechos y libertades individuales Sin
embargo a Costa de menos libertad y
menos garantías la medida ha
multiplicado la seguridad en el país las
cosas como son
como podéis ver la cifra de homicidios
anuales en El Salvador ha estado cayendo
desde 2016 pero es innegable que bukele
ha logrado cifras radicalmente más bajas
Aunque eso sí lo ha hecho a Costa de
cuestiones tan importantes como la
seguridad jurídica la presunción de
inocencia y las garantías procesales y
luego está por ver qué ocurre con Los
Grandes narcotraficantes pero está claro
que todas estas cosas en lugares como
Haití tampoco parece que les importen
demasiado porque tampoco es que existan
por eso no puede sorprendernos que la
estrategia de bukele haya sido
considerada un éxito y ahora el gobierno
haitiano se esté planteando intenta
replicarla en el país Haití inmovilizar
a sus fuerzas armadas contra las
pandillas ahora bien creéis que Ariel
Enric podría ser capaz de hacer lo mismo
que bukele en El Salvador desde luego en
el país ya no hay Apenas libertades ni
derechos que perder las bandas ejercen
su violencia constantemente a través de
violaciones saqueos asesinatos
secuestros extorsiones y demás acciones
por el estilo por ese lado no parece que
hubiese mucho problema pero qué ocurre
con las capacidades reales de Haití es
decir con su restablecido ejército su
policía y su capacidad penitenciaria
pues queridos amigos de visualpolitik la
verdad es que con los datos en la mano
parece difícil que el gobierno de Haití
pueda marcarse un bukele
como podéis ver Haití un país que tiene
casi el doble de población que El
Salvador tiene menos de la mitad de
policías un ejército de miniaturas y una
capacidad penitenciaria muy escasa
especialmente después de la construcción
de la megacárcel del Salvador que va a
poder albergar hasta 40.000 presos más
lo curioso de todo esto por cierto es
que entre 2019 y 2021 Haití recibió
cerca de 2.500 millones de dólares de
ayuda internacional que como veis no han
valido de mucho tener presente que a ti
es según transparencia internacional uno
de los 10 países más corruptos de todo
el planeta así que por ahí tampoco
parece que haya muchas esperanzas En
otras palabras que el futuro de Haití No
pinta precisamente bien seguro que ahora
entendéis mejor Por qué este es el país
más pobre de toda América La pregunta es
creéis que merecería la pena que Estados
Unidos vuelva a intentar estabilizar
Haití Cómo puede combatirse la
corrupción en Haití logrará Henry dar
con la clave para acabar con las bandas
Cuál es la mejor fórmula para luchar
contra la violencia y otra pregunta qué
imagen tenías de Haití déjanos tus
impresiones en los comentarios y
hablamos debate como siempre no olvides
que aquí en visualpolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones no os olvidéis
tampoco de echar un vistazo a Note news
en news.com un saludo y hasta pronto